the landscape artist who designed New
York City's Central Park believed that
providing scenic settings accessible to
all would not only benefit the public's
physical and mental health and also
foster a sense of democracy so
immediately this one sounds weird and
the reason why it sounds weird is that
we start saying not only and when you
see when you hear not only or when you
read a not only you expect to see a but
also so you would normally expect to see
someone saying hey I not only I not only
say ate a sandwich but I also or you
know but also I or even not only did he
eat a sandwich but also he ate a gay or
he drank a cola or he had some fries or
but he also so you would expect a but
also as part of that construction and we
see over here they do an end also so I
would look so I don't like it as it is
I'm going to rule out the first choice
that's always the one as it is so do
they have a but also here and they do
but also foster a sense of democracy so
the really the right one because
whenever you see a not only you also
want to see a but also so the landscape
artist who designed New York City's
Central Park believed that providing
scenic settings accessible to all would
not only benefit the public's physical
and mental health but also foster a
sense of democracy yeah that sounds
exactly right the not only says a not
only did you do this one thing but you
did other things but you also did this
other stuff so this one is definitely
the best answer